j'ai percé le secret du plus grand
mystère de l'univers le temps le temps
plus rien ne fonctionne ni téléphone ni
radio
nous sommes livrés à nous-mêmes
le grand Henri
a mené des expériences
[Musique]
c'est un nuage quantique qui donne accès
à des événements se produisant à
d'autres époques
en clair un portail vers le passé et le
futur entre le 22 août 1986 et le 22
août 2036
appelle le pouvoir ne doit pas rester
dans les mains d'un seul homme dans le
futur vous et votre frère allez
déclencher une guerre avec vos armes
alimentées en continuum
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons plus reculer
je ne laisserai personne se dresser sur
notre chemin
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas choisir notre époque
mais nous pouvons choisir ce que nous
allons léguer au futur
[Musique]